Evalúa la expresión "4n" elevado a la primera
potencia menos "2n" elevado a la potencia 0
para "n" igual a 1 y "n" igual a 5.
Hagamos primero "n" igual a 1, voy a reescribir
la expresión, donde veamos "n" ponemos 1.
Así que esto es igual a 4 por 1 elevado a
la potencia 1 menos 2 por 1 elevado a la potencia 0.
Donde vimos una "n" pusimos un 1, aquí teníamos
"n" a la primera potencia,
pusimos 1 a la primera potencia.
Y recuerda, para hacer las operaciones en
orden tenemos "PEMDAS".
Lo voy a poner por aquí, tenemos primero
paréntesis, luego la exponenciación,
luego multiplicación y división que tienen la
misma prioridad, finalmente tenemos la suma
o adición y la resta o substracción que
tienen la misma prioridad.
Así es que vamos a hacer los exponentes primero,
pues aquí no tenemos paréntesis.
Así es que evaluamos primero 1 a la potencia 1 y cuando elevamos algo a la potencia 1,
eso es igual a ese algo...
déjame ponerlo por aquí...
y si tengo "x" elevado a la potencia 1,
esto es igual a "x",
así es que 1 elevado a la potencia 1, es igual a 1.
Tenemos entonces que esto va a ser 4 por 1
menos 2 por 1, elevado a la potencia 0.
Ahora, cualquier número distinto de 0 elevado
a la potencia 0 es igual a 1.
Si tenemos entonces "x" elevado a la potencia 0,
¿esto a qué es igual?
si te digo que "x" es distinto que 0, entonces
debes de saber inmediatamente que "x" elevado
a la potencia 0 es igual a 1 y te digo que
"x" tiene que ser distinto de 0 pues 0 elevado
a la potencia 0, esto es indefinido, así
que esto es generalmente aceptado como indefinido.
Y quizás en un video próximo explicaré
porque esto es indefinido, pues por un lado
hay buenos argumentos de porque debería de
ser 0, pues 0 elevado a cualquier número
es siempre 0, pero también hay un argumento
válido porque debería de ser 1,
pues cualquier número elevado a la potencia 0, es 1.
Es por eso que esto en general se considera indefinido.
Y con eso en mente, 1 elevado a la potencia
0, va a ser simplemente 1,
cualquier número distinto de 0
elevado a la potencia 0 es 1.
Tenemos entonces 4 por 1 es 4
menos 2 por 1 es igual a 2,
finalmente 4 menos 2 es igual a 2.
Ahora, hagamos lo mismo con "n" igual a 5.
Esto es 4 por 5 a la potencia 1
menos 2 por 5 a la potencia 0.
Y es lo mismo, 5 a la potencia 1...
5 a la potencia 1, es iguala a 5...
déjame hacerlo mejor con otro color...
ahora sí, con este color...
5 a la potencia 1 es igual a 5 y
5 a la potencia 0 es igual a 1.
Entonces ahora tenemos, 4 por 5 menos 2 por 1.
Y esto va a ser igual, 4 por 5 es 20 menos 2 por 1 es 2...
2 por 1 es 2, 20 menos 2 es igual a 18.
Listo, hemos terminado.